so i wanted to start out by saying that
not only is dustin poirier one of the
greatest fighters to ever step in the
octagon and a great person
this this podcast is fueled by
rare stash
oh wow just going to take that it's his
new birthday he sent to me and i
i just told you that and you're gonna do
this so let's um well here we go give
him some problems gonna read about it
yeah oh he wrote oh he wrote brenda the
letter it's a nice letter and i love
dustin
he uh
this is the first bottle so it goes live
this friday this friday just in time for
the new year's new year's eve get you
some dustin poirier
it's uh stash rear stash the rear
stash.com but you can get it uh this
friday at reservebar.com
rear stash i like it man cheers buddy
can you try it cheers pal
cheers there you go cheers yeah cheers
cheers i can't believe you haven't
relapsed being around me so much i know
all i have is the finest whiskey's
around all the time
you know what's what's interesting about
it is that because you don't like you
don't get drunk you just drink like did
you like that taste yeah you know what i
mean
so you would think that like i'd be like
oh well if it's just tasting you know
yeah i would do it but still but if i
was like wilding out like if you were
like walling out oh that would that
probably stress me out
i'd be like brenda i can't go well he's
kind of he's kind of he's kind of big so
you'd have to yeah you have to figure it
out it's the wild it's the wild times
that stressed me out do you get a little
ornery when you get uh you just get
happy yeah happy i never get like you
don't get happy i mean
if i have to if it's like a friday set i
have two shows and like i'll do a double
before i go on stage i'll do a double
when i get off between the shows i'll do
another double you know a little bit
but he doesn't want to ride the edge we
want to ride
only twice a month it's only one i'm on
road twice a month yeah and then i drink
and then every five in the kitchen
it is yeah you know for yellowstone and
then for yellowstone i stopped drinking
during yellowstone oh you did that's
when i knew i was an addict yeah oh yeah
i wear a cowboy hat yeah
you get the whiskey out you do the damn
thing but it's so easy to just pop a
little whiskey i love how you love wine
yeah you are you are a wine guy i love
everything about it i love using it i
love with the region you do the you do
the shaking
yeah it's it's
it's hey why did they not pour it in
that they didn't pour it in a bottle for
you they poured it out
so you decant it because the oxygen gets
too light yeah it changes
so when you open a great bottle of wine
sometimes this is no joke the difference
between when you first open it in two
hours later is literally night and day
now did you stump the uh the waiter that
came to us because because he was like
uh and when god
when did you guys go to dinner
um it was monday night we went to yeah
we went to wally's wally's on monday
night didn't you go there before i don't
know no yeah yeah we did that
yeah that's my goat
this time i mean it wasn't
uh
your girl didn't come yeah that was just
guys here chapelle this is take it from
me i've been a million dinners with
brian whenever there's a wine you take
the wine and you just you when you do
you do this yo
you try and yield it's that's earthy
that is earthy
people are going to think you know what
you're talking about there you go there
you go that's my go-to
even if it's a sweet line i go
oh that's earth
and then throw some of this in there
throw some of this in there go like this
go go go go
got some mushrooms too huh a little
leather yeah you take you smell it
mushrooms they're not making that
is there a caramel scent am i crazy and
you just start throwing that out and
then his rich friends like holy [ __ ]
chappelle is educated educated and then
do this sometimes do this present me
with the bottle good here you go bruh
let's see it it's 2014. yeah i don't
like that year
let's go if you've got i got you better
present me one i got this one
wow that's a 97 wow that was nice you
know what that year a little sour for me
[Laughter]
yeah
a little sour and that just dumped it i
figured out that's how you get it it
doesn't make anything with it
he got specific with the year and
everything oh yeah i was like this guy
[ __ ] well because i knew
i knew that region and i know the
difference between 2014 2015. not a big
deal how how how
does what is the difference because some
years so so so why would a 2014 be 100
dollars less than the 2015 only because
that year across the board a lot of
times for bordeaux in that region just
wasn't so good that does not rocket
science it's just an agreed-upon thing
and then i've had those ones and i
didn't believe it and i go ah [ __ ] i
i'm not picky and then i have those
wines and i go oh damn they're
right dude
he pronounces this [ __ ] yeah correctly
yep get off his nest but any time hey
man i'm just i'm excited
listen i can't be impressed come on come
on come on you know what it is but i
can't be impressed but anytime there's
wine just go not my year not my year
whatever it is
you know what i'm with friends i'll try
it every no matter what the one night i
mean i doubt i'll drink wine ever again
no but just act like you know what
you're talking like i know what i'm
talking about yeah
i could be like i don't i don't drink
but you know what that year i know like
when i did not my year
and they're all going to respect you and
then throughout earthy not earthy
and by the way you know
you can just it's easy to learn it's
easy to look like you know what you're
talking about without knowing too much
let's not get crazy that's 99 of people
yeah this is like a real expert but see
you can't really do that with whiskey
i think whiskeys have but
but like there's so many
listen i'm a whiskey connoisseur this is
a bourbon i'm more of a bourbon guy and
this is the first of all it doesn't pray
i don't i i'm pretty sure he had a hand
in making it hopefully didn't there's
just a name on it but it's 91 proof so
that's already a good sign that's oh
that's right it's also what doesn't have
to be at least 10 years in the barrel
yeah yeah
yeah but see i know the difference
between
uh wild turkey and jack daniels and like
knob creek and stuff like that like i
know the difference okay
you could tell big time but like you
could tell that with wine
yes it's that it has that oh yeah i mean
i can do diet coke and coke dude i do i
prove that all the time i always do
those blind taste tests because i like
to do that do you really yes i can tell
you oh when we do cabernet
you know sure sure when we do the when
we go to super cats and we do the amas
that's exactly what we're gonna do for
the first ama i'm gonna blindfold you
and get some expensive wine and then
just that cheap box wine do it and see
me and tell the difference yeah i'll be
able to tell yeah i'll be able to tell
without tasting yeah you'll be able to
tell you're gonna smell it you can just
smell it and tell me oh i can't wait
you're sure and in fact i'll do you one
better i bet you get pinot noir get a
cabernet get a french cabernet get a
california cabernet and you'll be able
to tell the difference and and and now
hold on i'm gonna do one better and then
and then do a pinot no that's too many
no you you first of all you're just all
very different
i'll be able to smell it
you can't you can't tell that tastes
good
because you you know the gig is oh yeah
yeah three different ones okay yeah i
can i can already tell
what's
is white wine not as popular i'm just
not as big a white wine person but i
don't know that i can tell the
difference between a french chablis for
example and a california chardonnay
which is really easy you could too or or
a sauvignon blanc it's pretty easy to
tell you said that you know but because
that's different um
then but does white white wine doesn't
have many uh health benefits as red wine
i don't know i don't know yeah so is
that true too because they say red wine
is like good for the good for your heart
or something like that maybe
i don't think so i i would say white
wine red wine i would say wine when
paired with a good meal and good friends
is good for you yeah
what does that mean cardiovascular like
we know this sure
but also so is hanging out with your
friends
the vibe the other depends on the
friends if your friend's doing a bunch
of cocaine
yeah yeah but i'm saying like when they
say the health benefits is it that or is
it just that there's definitely
time to drink
and you can tell the difference of
course oh you really can't
i don't know wow
oh we gotta we gotta take them to
walmart
yeah
i'm gonna call y'all right now now that
i've gotten into whiskey and fine
whiskeys and bourbons
growing up his every restaurant would go
to he'd order a seven and seven
he's he'd always go do you have scene
grubs uh in uh seagram's seven right
yeah vo and i thought because he would
ask for it everywhere i thought it was
like top shelf like the most
seagram's is bottom shelf like it's the
lowest yeah but it's that's that's what
you like
if you're mixing it with something
it doesn't matter so much but that that
was just like you didn't want to switch
with anything else
yeah you love vo yeah
yeah so you you can get into this whole
this whole bourbon thing and
my dad swears by scotch yeah my father
would be like i drink scotch because of
the water in scotland sure all right
wait wait is that true oh there's
definitely he'll say that and he'll
spend a lot of money on a mcallen's 18.
i don't think yeah but there's there's
some whiskey's like uh like look at your
dad like there's one in colorado where
it uses the colorado water and it tastes
it tastes better by the way so you could
tell the difference from the water like
that give me a second look at papa
look at papa shop's frame he's got you
he's every bit as tall as you are yep i
don't see any gut there i see chest and
i see
arms i got the vein in the arm yep
that's a guy who's never stopped working
out no no never never stopped working
out ever wow always been super healthy i
mean i don't see any there's not a
there's no belly there that's a flat
stomach oh yeah my pop is in shape man
papa shop no we i mean even as kids like
i do it with tiger now like
we'd walk every single night man
everybody's going to walk here every
night me jay and him would walk every
night oh yeah walking is the best thing
for you
i did that this morning i went on my
hike yeah i walk i walk every morning
now there's been a morning there's
pick yourself up a little a little
present this weekend yep christmas
christmas came early christmas came
early now i'm not a car guy but i do
have to say i sort of parked outside in
the rain uh if there was a car
that's made like jewelry that is as
beautiful as it gets
that color is sick there's me and my dad
having a great time what kind of car is
that that is
yeah there's a fry f8 tribute to spider
and uh hey that's that that uh a lot of
room in the back british screen yeah
there's not a lot of room in the back
well there's no back seats bro looks
like it looks like it looks like a
go-kart well there's no back it's a it's
a race car i'm aware of that you were
you were uh you were a kung fu smoke for
that was there you're talking about the
denim coat i'm asking you about your
kung fu smock oh the denim coat i'm
asking
i don't know
where i'm asking you a question real
talk i would wear the [ __ ] out of that
thing well he looks like he's got a he
looks like a he looks like a fisherman
he looks like he's just got from whaling
and there's nothing wrong with that but
you're picking up your flurry
i caught a lot of crabs
bought a ferrari with the crab nothing
wrong with that
those are your fellow seamen those two
guys are yeah
that's the first time that guy's been in
a [ __ ] suit and that guy
no the guy in the back well
what are you talking about the guy in
the with the ties he's sorry i'm talking
about that's a hell of a beard that
beard has got a mind of its own that's
just amazing that'll keep you warm and a
blizzard he's mr ferrari are we no he he
is who is who is he he's the like
overall manager of ferrari so he knows
this [ __ ] oh man now what about the guy
with the uh the beard there greg
climber is my business partner you know
greg okay
yeah greg so like to get allocated to
fry that's why it's a big deal so my dad
flew out here like get allocated fried
be like for a car guy it's like
for i'm trying to compare so for it'd be
like getting past at the improv for the
coming story like it's like a path like
it's a big deal oh like you're in the
club so you can you can go and buy one
no no no no really no no you buy a used
one but for like to get at msrp and be
part of the club and before like the
sf90 spyder comes out next year
they come to you because you're part of
the club and you get an msrp so let's
see msrp so msrp so that you get it for
cost so
the reason why being part of the club's
so cool it's also a business investment
these cars because you can turn around
right now and sell that yeah for
hundreds of thousands of dollars more
because they're so exclusive they're so
hard to get that since you're in the
club fry comes to you first goes hey we
allocated you a f8 or sf90 or a law
ferrari wow do you want it before we get
so what you got is limited people oh all
ferraris are but then they're so limited
so there's such a
a market for it
that um
man i wish they didn't zoom in on the
other
keyboard oh there we go
um there's such a market for it that the
demand
over is way over the supply supply so
there's always a market for it so it's a
business investment so you have that and
then driving that car for free you're
getting paid to drive the correct way
correct wow and so you have that and
then the sf-90 that i ordered comes in
june so when that comes i get rid of
that i get that's f90 then you hold on
to that why do you want the fs fs90 over
that that looks great it does wait to
see the sf90
because that's f90 is more exclusive and
it's 1100 horsepower and it's we saw it
yesterday it's
insane dude but already i'm stressed out
about driving like so now you'll be
driving that car all the time is that
your that's not your number one driver
no the poor's still the daily drive of
the gt2 still my daily but that ferrari
that's that's it that mimic our time out
this morning like you're you're in this
like club you're in this game
and it's like all right well if you do
it just for money don't drive it leave
in the garage don't let it get dinged
don't put miles on it because you want
so many people i love the car yeah but
my thing is it's like i love driving
it's kind of stupid it's like i like to
like i drive you drive the [ __ ] out of
your car i have eleven is it like
flipping shoes i mean no but he no he
drives like those guys anybody who has a
car like that it sits in the garage okay
anybody i know has those cars they never
have driven it ever he drives his car
every day like a driver it's like his
truck okay yeah i like i like to drive
him it's outrageous so the that's the me
my talk about this morning is like
that's the dilemma it's like all right
well if you're doing this
like the smart thing to do is not drive
it leave it pristine conditional put
miles on it get the most money for it to
me it's like that's not fun like that's
not why i want to do this i want this
because i want the access to the cars i
might make a little less money when i
flip it but i'll be driving the goddamn
thing why is why does it say it's a
plug-in dream sf90 is a hybrid so it's
the first hybrid no it's 1100 horsepower
but a v6 also
has two other engines down so it's
electric what so i can drive the studio
just on the electric why is the gas
but every single person we talked to at
ferrari goes we've driven all law
ferraris daytona every friday like
nothing compares that's f90 it's nuts i
don't know i like green is a beautiful
car though that's that yeah i like that
i like the green oh it is so good i only
get my cars in green let me see the
other let me see the shape of the sf the
the first one that you bought the f8
yeah i love that shape yeah it's
actually a cooler shape i don't know you
have a picture of the inside it's
smaller though yeah that's smaller isn't
it or are you just a giant no just a
giant you don't make them for giants
usually well that's the thing about
ferraris they make them for like i can
fit in almost any fry but some of the
coops if they're straight hard tops yeah
hard make it a little tough but
that's why like frying porsche i only
really messed with them because i don't
really fit in a certain mclaren's i can
fit on mclaren's 765 lt
that's that's the sf-90 that is i think
i'll go back to that
mike has a carbon fiber kit from private
rooms
it's so they're so stressful though no
one let's talk about that it's so
stressful because if somebody oh that's
my car
mine's spider
mine's the spider so it's convertible
which is rare uh it's a beautiful car
it's
it's a super car yeah yeah
so so you got to figure out like all
right well if you're doing it for
investment look at like art don't touch
it don't drive it and to me it's like
now they have access to it now let me
take the wheels for a space i just think
if you love cars the way you do than you
drive it well same thing with my shoe
like you know i love shoes and cars so
it's like also with like shoes like have
you ever seen me just put away some
shoes that's what i was saying you know
like i
rode down a mountain with in on a
mountain bike oh yeah you know
yeah and destroyed them but it's also
like the that's yeah the kevin hart got
but so so that's see how it's
convertible kevin hart got the first
sf90 spider in north america so
we have a friend very close friend who i
got in the allocation program and he
ordered that exact carbon in matte black
and it's going to be a year before he
gets this
because they they don't they just don't
build them and then sell them it's all
custom you pick down to the stitching
dude down the i had to pick the brake
calipers the stitching the the door
handle yeah i mean the back everything
the straps everything if you're in the
car's mouth yeah but i'll tell you what
would and my dad can vouch for this like
you know i bought a lot of cool cars but
with ferrari they made it so special man
and i was just gonna put it on a truck
and have them
drive it from san diego to l.a my dad's
like what the when when are you how many
times are you gonna buy a [ __ ]
ferrari like this we're driving down
there we're getting experience and we
got there in the manager he was like
yeah especially for first-timers like
you're in the club this is your first
time he's like come and make a special
date we walk in it's in the middle of
the showroom it has a red tarp over it
they had a special champagne they all
offered
they had a special cupcakes that said
congratulations thick boy
like
when i got my tesla the first one they
had
they wrapped it in a bow and they took
me in the back and i was like this is
the best
it looks so amazing
i can't imagine a ferrari
same thing congratulations on your f8
spider
won't open that but it's just uh yeah
it's really cool man it was really good
i see why it's stressful though that's a
big day yesterday uh yeah it's stressful
yeah i see why it can be stressful that
yeah that's a stressful that's a big
deal
yeah well stressful and i don't want to
ding it you know but yeah that's the
other thing it's like like i'm not
stressed out about my porsche even
though it's the supercar i'm not
stressed out about that's my i can get
it fixed it's whatever i'm not worried
about flipping it or whatever yeah but
the ferrari it's like it's so stressful
it's a piece of art it's so stressful
and they're fragile yeah it's a
nightmare yeah it's a nice such a piece
of art
and then also i think a lot of people i
mean obviously kevin hart did and the
rock dudes on that rogan won't post any
of his cars
you really won't post anything yet and
like i think him like i struggle with
this like do you post this stuff like is
this like bragging stuff like that and i
think i come from i was talking a giant
christian about this
and my girl i think i come from a
different kind of cut of cloth where
we've been doing the show so long like
you and i have been talking with mike so
long when we started like i needed money
from you to buy t-shirts to start find
the kid t-shirts have a kidney fight
club like i couldn't are you [ __ ]
kidding me i could buy a ferrari so i
think the fans have
come up with me and they and they
realize the hard work but it's like it's
all of us so i post that stuff to show
like i'm an idiot man
anybody can do it right that's what
that's what i'm saying i can do this
like check this out man this dude
podcasting and stand up dude yeah stand
up and podcast and bought that ferrari
yeah
it's a great thing yeah i uh that's why
i like to post that stuff yeah i didn't
i didn't think that you were being
pregnant i don't think that's a brag no
yeah i mean i just know you i mean i
just know how much you love cars i i
don't think you've ever made any bones
about how much you love them and please
plus
a huge deal oh yeah i mean it is the
allocated ones i can understand people
being like oh look at him showing off
but i i feel like you've always talked
about cars and
you know part of it's like you're still
super excited about it you're like
you're kind of blown away by it oh yeah
also i don't think i i you know i mean
people can say what they want but i mean
i think if you're
if you're that honest about you're like
holy [ __ ] i got a ferrari that's
organically a big deal to be in the club
like to be in there i mean i'm not in
the cars but i looked at it i saw it
i was like oh [ __ ] like to be in the
club i'm in the club i didn't know that
like they let me in the club and now
when they have what's that car thing you
go to dad in uh northern california
what's it called
monterey where they have the car show
yeah so they'll have the most exclusive
ferraris like they're just msrp like 1.4
million there's only 500 of them
there'll be 40 of them there so on the
regular market they sell for 3 million
i'm never going to touch those cars
they have 30 of them and ferrari if
you're not in the club you excuse me no
you can't go in and do the thing and get
all the treatment stuff like that but if
you own a ferrari if you're part of that
club you get a access to that you meet
other ferrari drivers and it's just like
this whole it's a marker yeah it's like
this weird club that you're in but it's
also a marker in your life it's a turn
it's like a
you know we always talk about how
important it is to celebrate we never
celebrate i suck at that so that's kind
of a mini celebration it's like i look
look what i look like
yeah you
yeah that's fair to say i mean when i
got in i looked right down like how
[ __ ] crazy it is
it is yeah
it's stressful
yeah but it's cool though you can die
tomorrow you know so it's like yeah yeah
you want to drive the [ __ ] i think
there's a yeah i mean i i drove in the
ring today my uncle bought uh an austin
healey
and he loved cars but it it sat he had
the real spokes i remember he broke it
down that was a young guy but it would
just sit in the it would sit in the
garage he never drove out yeah i always
thought to myself you're gonna buy a car
drive it
i mean i don't know
otherwise just invest in art i'm not
[ __ ] about art i know about cars yeah
but you know
yeah some guys buy the cars and just not
do anything with it and then they just
flip them it's like well that's not but
that's what i love about what you do is
i'm not into cars but you you truly
drive the [ __ ]
and then you also but you like that bro
you like your bronco too love the bronco
yeah just different yeah
love the bronco
how's that situation going what your bar
and stuff did you just know what you
didn't send your bar oh with rough
country they remember on the last uh
episode i went hard in the paint and
told rough country you [ __ ] me yeah
they reached out yeah
so
they made it right didn't they
oh they made it right and the the guy
reached out he's like hey man
he's like we're always in the show in
the [ __ ] office
he's like we didn't shout out to rough
country yeah shout out to them they're
like they're like if you look at this i
mean let's be fair ruff gun he's like if
you look at the small print it says that
this nerf bar fits this type of bronco
yours is the first edition we didn't
make my first edition but i didn't order
it my girl ordered it oh okay so honest
mistake yep so
this is what so he said uh
uh he said i understand blah blah blah
says sister though thanks for responding
um don't make me send my manager out
there to rough you up
he's funny he's funny and his name is uh
tim watts shot to tim watts at rough
country but then he goes uh our guy
chase foster uh he's that guy who will
come rough you up if you want uh give
him a shout out man so let's just shout
out uh chase foster chase foster don't
come and [ __ ] up brandon so yeah please
create him he came in he just leg kicked
you and punched you'd be like
chase foster this guy from rough country
rough brendan up he just sponsored me in
stumbling blocks
yeah yeah now you're a rough country and
he just walks away oh no he punched me
in the stomach and goes welcome to rough
country
like why it doesn't make sense man
or he comes down i beat the [ __ ] out of
him anyways um
so uh yeah shout out to tim watts and
chase especially chase foster for
bringing it to everybody's attention uh
no no ill will man i love you guys and
now uh chin's bringing up uh chase
foster i wish she wouldn't do that
because
it's there but i like that name no i
could get his name chase foster chase
foster yeah nice dude
now they did say rough countries just
say we're working on one for the first
edition and when we make it and it's
ready to go we will send you it on the
house he said we'll also take your one
and you can send it back and get a full
refund
good company great company oh they're a
great company i always use them but
too much work too much work yeah i'm
gonna send it back now tim if you could
send somebody to come to the house
box it all up and then take it you have
to send chase foster you're going to
want you up and you're picking up
chase foster
if you don't want a bow tie
he doesn't i don't like to judge a book
by his cover i'm not gonna do it but i
just don't i don't know that he's going
to be able to beat brennan up i don't
know if he's going to rough brennan up
we don't know anything about chase no
but i'm looking at him you don't know
anything about him he might be like
dexter morgan it might be [ __ ] nice
with the hands he might hit me with a
needle of the neck
i wake up naked there you go naked and
there you go and you know what you see
and then you'd see me in the background
and i'm like yeah thanks for the ferrari
yeah
yeah hey i'll i'll drive her real good
that's not nice no
i just closed i shot the rough country
yeah they said they're gonna send it
once once they have it that's good shout
out to rough country i'm sorry
i'm sorry i went bad on you guys there
first of all yeah you went pretty hard
i thought they [ __ ] me i made a
mistake
my wife [ __ ] me
merry christmas brandon
here here's a 300 pound uh uh
nerf bar that doesn't fit so there you
go there we go everyone wants it i mean
put on your previous dude or would you
it's a tesla dude yeah don't say prius
all right
don't say prius don't say priest i'll
tell you something else i'm doing
something though same thing no it my car
is very fast yeah sure it takes no
prisoners and i'll tell you something
else yeah charge it i'm getting these
three i should charge it
oh dude drive to san diego on that thing
let me know how it goes for you drive
there and back i can get there
why wouldn't it get right there good
it's a tesla can't go back
excuse me excuse me
it's only 300. excuse me excuse me i'm
getting the 3 series with the extended
battery life that's the little game 304
it's white on white are you getting the
roseanne tesla you're talking about the
little one it's small it's no nonsense
zips that is no it's not bad
it's cause
it's too big i don't need it i need the
small i need a small and i'm gonna zip
around by the way
no
you might as well ask them hey are you
in the guys
meet peter shop in the tesla's no we're
anti-tesla dude you're getting a [ __ ]
electric ferrari yeah right exactly oh
okay it's half yeah that's still
electrical you're half gay a little bit
which you are anyway no
no
yeah but you you know what's real gay is
when guys go it's just too much car you
know i don't need all that
oh is it too much car that's like guys
you're not driving in these shoes all
day you're not driving that
s350 it's a [ __ ] tesla they're not
big it's not just you're driving an
s-class i drove a prius and i loved it
for a long time do you still have that
breeze no but i miss it you miss it yeah
i gave it to a friend you're a simple
man when it comes to the car simple
that's fair i'm a simple man i really i
dig that yeah get that little two-door
tesla man it's not a two-dimensional i
think it's a four-door after the
four-door i'm not sure white right i'm
getting white on white oh you're going
to get a white car yeah it just looks
super i mean i agree with your
testimonies it looks like it looks like
a little space ball and i like it
bring it up man
it's the exact same car that kyle drives
it's the same car
now does it come with a six-pack of my
cards lemonade
there she is she has a different one
that's not the one yeah
that's a good card yeah that's awesome
dude i could get black rims get one of
these
dude come on dude
that thing is zips
zips we call that the win that wheel
whatever you could do yeah you do those
whatever happened i just set it on fire
uh whatever happened to the tesla truck
remember all that and you got a cyborg
was uh i think it was seen i think they
had some problems those were cool
looking yeah those are cool looking
but my my my car is kind of
cyber truck release date what'd you call
your car late 22. the wheel 2022 the
whip
yeah those look pretty beefy those look
pretty that's insane yeah
it is pretty badass actually yeah they
look pretty cool you drive
that brian i would
well if your
standard tesla's too big for you that
thing is weight yeah that ain't free you
know is that a prototype or is that what
it's going to look like no that's what
it's going to look like wow it looks
dope those tesla plaids are monsters
they're so fast rogan has one they're so
fast crazy
tesla what i mean i mean if you're into
speed but you're not just in speed
you're in the art of the car right yeah
i mean electric does nothing for me yeah
it's a passion yeah different thing i
don't care for me cars are point a to
point b and i got a tesla because i
didn't have to get up put gas in it and
it was safe look at that
but do you have a
charger at the house
yeah and yeah but you're talking to the
guy who drove a barcelona red prius they
even tried to get me
they go please don't get red the guy was
like this is so gay
i go i want red because it's gay i want
red and i want to call it the red ramp
that steering wheel it's like you're
already driving a a video game and the
steering wheel just as i don't like that
steering wheel do you like no you're
talking about the lego thing the sun has
legos that have that yeah
that's so stupid yeah the screen's cool
i guess right
screams i'm just not
i just don't appreciate it i mean i
wonder how you feel if you drove the
ludicrous though
you know
faster than everything else it's just
not that impressive
faster
what is it about it you don't really
drive the car fast you just drive i
don't drive that fast you like the art
you like the art you like the reason you
like shoes
i like the style of it yeah the history
of it there's no history first of all
yeah it's also anybody that drives a
tesla this weird like i get it brendan i
get it don't say you don't drive fast
you drive fast not really compared to
you yeah yo you driving driven with him
bro it's like driving it's like it's
like driving my aunt nubby yeah it's
like dude
go very sensible it is he's the speed
limit he drives the speed limit that's a
huge yeah oh yeah to two maybe five
under yeah and then radios like beer you
can barely hear i'm like dude i drive
pretty fast
no in comparison like i'm always 20
miles an hour over this i can't do the
speed limit like if you're driving 25
miles 45 miles an hour i'm just like oh
if you're ever going to get something
when we're driving in san diego
yesterday on the highway it's like it
says 65 there's not a single soul going
eight it's 80s though chappelle's
driving i'll drive 65 in a [ __ ]
heartbeat yeah and i'll stay there yeah
music at a certain tone just different
different types of people out there yeah
everybody loves chappelle when he comes
to dinner
anyone who doesn't like i love that guy
well i love him my buddy gil was like
and he's so cute i just he's got he's
such a handsome face i was like
that's cool
i was like hey what are you talking
about i got a cute face i loved you
i mean
well i guess maybe it's the still have a
hot wife today some ideas for he has not
he has got girlfriends
oh he's single yeah how old is he 65 60
yeah
you thought chappelle's cute
yeah you're not a gay man though yeah no
no no that's crazy talk but he will look
at a man ago you're why why why do you
say i was cute like he could say other
words yeah like you know he's holding
some schools he's older yeah handsome is
he just older though and he just lights
you i thought you were smart
and and and she had a good soul
it doesn't matter like whatever follows
you yeah it's just like he was cute what
about what about my you said intelligent
you said smart but jimmy burke does that
jimmy burke will be like he's a dish huh
he's a real dish yeah but he's joking
but he'll be like i mean with big brown
eyes full mouth like that the great nose
i'm like hey bro um this is so detailed
jimmy's a jokester though so i'll take
care yeah his friend calls you up and
goes hey that guy's cute man yeah
yeah this is besides we call you up huh
he's cute he's cute but he'll do that
he's cute but he he does he does have
that style he's just it's the older
style yeah probably i get it right
no i don't know you guys say black guys
are cute you know what i'm saying like
to call him up out of the blue i'm like
hey you're hey that guy's cute man
that's it man he had a great smile
gank hey does he need any money or
anything like that like i don't know all
right place the state help with his rent
or something
do you have his number looks like he has
strong hands put it together put it
together on a text text yeah put us in a
group text
right like oh yeah right
okay
there is all that stuff
like some dudes are like you know
where they're like they just say
something you're like huh they're like
you you wear that well
huh what what yeah
you just said i look good in it
cute yeah cute so tough to get by cute
yeah
is there what do you mean an older guy
recently because you know i used to be
looking you still got it you're still a
great looking guy i used to be like that
that's him fishing for compliments like
oh thank you but yeah he's not hitting
on you with that i was like no no not
tim just yeah self-esteem fishing for
compliments and you're just like cool
man and kept going yeah yeah now you
look great too
yeah right it was like i don't think
that'd be so awkward the best the best
was i called you i don't know john wayne
parr who's a great fighter and a great
guy but john
john because he's a fighter a lot of
fighters their their faces get you know
it's a hard life john's face like
frankenstein he's got he's got he blinds
he's john wayne park
one of the great hall of famer
kickboxing i mean he's from australia
he's a handsome guy don't get me wrong
he's a guy great guy but but but but a
real man's man has been through a lot
he'll post some of the uh like his scars
and stuff his kids right now but he's
got deep lines man like he's got demise
and i and i tell you well that guy on
the rights lived the harshest thing oh
god
well that's that's the dad from rick and
morty bring that up jim that's amazing
wait hon
said let me introduce you to that guy
let me see let me introduce you who is
84. change them twice a week man oh
that's pretty personal
uh body punch is a finish look at that
dude 84 dude dad from rick and morty uh
i don't know yeah he's 84. don't do
something no this isn't diss them this
is facts dude
there he goes that's what he looks like
not so much you don't think so i mean
[ __ ] usually
i [ __ ] t if dad from rick and morty
go back gin uh-huh go to the grandpa
right there you see him yes
there he is a cartoon yeah dude at 84 i
hope i'm doing that that's impressive as
hell yeah
but john john looks at him and
brandon on rogan goes
he just looks at him and he goes what i
said to him
goes brennan goes hold you and john goes
38 and brennan goes like this without
missing a baby brennan goes you look
young
no he doesn't
right in front of him but he's such a
man oh look at that face
like i said that frankenstein he's all
man oh such a good person too such a
badass yeah oh super legendary
australian legend he gave my shows in
australia remember that yeah i came to
the show yeah
australia oh he does yeah
wow that's like a
collage of all the scars that he had oh
not from like fight no
it's amazing man be able to train with a
guy like that wow
yeah he's yeah
yeah those elbows and shaking him take
it's toll on your face yeah super super
famous over there too everyone yeah he's
like tom cruise yeah he's getting
walking through the world of kickboxing
you know
all right what do you got jen
i need my nutrition i need my energy and
i'm trying to figure out how i can drink
my nutrition do you have anything
tasty i want it tasty do you want it
green i want to get my greens i want to
get my phytonutrients my bioflavonoids i
want to get my vegetables i'm going to
do my probiotics i want to get myself
it's so funny to me you brought this up
because today's podcast finding a kid
yeah live laugh love is brought to you
by ag1 what's happening
one tasty green scoop of ag1 contains 75
vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
what is a problem mineral and a
probiotic probiotics is there a green
superfood blend yes man is this athletic
greens one yeah it's so delicious
oh it tastes fantastic i put in eight
ounces of water and your boy hits the
ground
running
all right and to make it easy athletic
green is gonna give you guys immune
support
free one year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs listen you know
cold flu season popping up you need that
strong immune system that's where
vitamin d comes into play here and you
can get again a free one year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel backs of
ag-one with your first first purchase if
you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter today again visit athletic
greens.com fighter take control of your
health and give eighty-one a try b how
many times have you gone to the pharmacy
and you're like what how much is it well
you got your perspective i got my i got
my if i'm going for my my propecia for
my head whatever it might be i need my
medicine now here's the problem i got a
problem whenever you go to get your
prescription if you go to one pharmacy
they can charge you as much as a hundred
dollars more than the other farm so you
never know where you're going to get
dude and and it's expensive so i need
somebody who can shop around dude
broseph bros of my older friend you need
good rx all right alright good rx
because they're going to get you the
lowest price but what good rx allows you
to do instantly they allow you to
compare prices at pharmacies in your
neighborhood before you go so you know
exactly what you can pay when you get
there okay checking good rx is free it's
easy takes only a few seconds to find
discounts that can save you up to 80
80 yes and listen many of times all
right good rx will beat your insurance
or medicare copay price so even if you
have insurance you should check good rx
to see if you can get a lower freaking
price that's impressive listen and good
rx the app is the number one most
download medical app all right so we get
you guys covered so for simple smart
savings on your prescriptions check good
rx turn off your phone and check goodrx
go to goodrx.com
that's good rx.com fighter
goodrx.com good rx is not insurance but
can be used instead of insurance in 2020
goodrx users save an average of 79 off
retail prices
look
the thing about health is you want to
make sure you optimize the thing is if
you don't have health care compromise
right now dude i know
you got a coffee all the time dude okay
you know what i stopped using my honor i
got you dude it's about on it it's about
optimizing it's about god you need your
focus you said they got their their
flagship is alpha brain they got alpha
brains and they got alpha brain black
label they got dude i only roll without
the brain black labels sometimes your
mood's off so you want to get some good
sleep they got new mood they got new
mood krill oil joint you know as you get
older the joints tell me how the joints
are popping you got to get your acrylic
dude that's good for your brain yeah man
we got creatine protein powder coffee
dark roast coffee uh what protein bars
protein bites
warrior bars oh my god
on-demand workouts home fitness programs
they even got certifications if you want
to if you want to get an honest
certification it never ends they got
hydrocarb core bags they got everything
you need
listen everything listen if you're thick
ass trying in shape for this for 2022 i
would order on it right now because
hopefully it comes in time for the new
year on it.com slash fighter 10 off air
thing all right
so 2022 let's bring in the right way the
healthy way and let's fight this thing
together yeah don't be sick be strong
and stay thick
on it.com fighter
alrighty
dang this microphone
here we go
so this is a little update to the travis
scott situation with all of his collabs
i guess dior and him have mutually
agreed to
pull the cactus jack collab that they
were going to release in 2022. that
means dior was like okay we're all set
how do you want to release this yeah and
i also heard nike's actually going to
completely be done with him same thing
happened with because of this concert
yeah
with his uh seltzer company i guess
whoever manufactures uh cactus i think
it's called cacti yeah his heart's ulcer
is actually pulling out as well i i just
think it's pretty harsh to do that i i
think it was a terrible tragedy but how
much did he have to do with that yeah i
agree yeah i mean then again he did say
i mean he kind of incited riots right
obviously he didn't want that he's not a
guy who wanted people to die no of
course not i don't think yeah it's also
like people that go to his concert like
they know like he goes hard in the paint
and he goes like you know it's like a
it's like a a mosh like that's what they
do
i think corporations are going this is
not the best time right now because
you're
people may not buy as much of the
product because of this so let's just
wait oh i think he's more famous after
this i think his ticket sales go through
the roof i think when when kids go [ __ ]
i could die you know kids are [ __ ] i
could die yeah the ticket sale goes up
yeah that's because they're insane yeah
no you're right yeah i'll be interesting
to see you guys look at christian he's
young he's hip yeah it made me want to
go to one more where you go i've never
been able to even survive it there you
go yeah kids are crazy they all talk
about how like crazy those shows are so
it's like
but also with uh the people around the
hook there's live nation like they
provide the security the venue all that
stuff right and then also his thing he's
just showing up like but then also with
security it's like before we even touch
the stage four hours before they had
issues with people getting trained and
stuff like that so it's like
travis scott doesn't specialize in
security or or but also but also in
crowd control but also in his concerts
like even when you're on stage you know
i'm sure your fans are crazy older but
when they go crazy
like you can't excuse me like you can't
tell if someone passed out or they're
dead like especially thinking about him
about 50 000 people a sea of people like
people like every concert you've ever
done someone has passed out i can't see
them when people like well we're yelling
at him this person is dead it's like
yeah you're in the 20th road you can't
hear and he has he has things in his ear
there's [ __ ] lights
you can't see the audience
those lights are on you you can't see i
think people have never performed before
oh that's ridiculous i bet he could see
what's going on it's like there's not a
chance right
and him and drake they're like suing for
billions of dollars it's gonna fall on
live nation
well i mean yeah
you're not again your your job is to
perform an edu you know yeah
you cannot you're not a you're not an
expert in exits and that's exactly why
can you imagine if you went to a club
and there's a million hecklers and the
club went that's on you dude like you
got to figure it out it's like i can't
con
that's not my mo man that's not my in my
job description like you have security
here to keep these guys safe and for
everybody to enjoy the show so if
there's hecklers you got to shut them
down if there's one i can have fun with
it but if it's 10 hecklers then what
what's security doing here that's that's
i assume they're going to control the
situation so i think for travis scott
like he assumed the situation was
controlled he also can't see in a sea of
50 000 people
well exactly he puts that in the
securities hands and like you said if
they knew people were getting trampled
before he had gone on stage
they should have they should have told
him
they should have made him aware of that
but then he went on again i didn't make
him awake because what's he in all right
i guess i won't go or just like we'll be
like those people like hey don't go up
yet there there's we got to control no
no live nation should but hey we need
more security here man like we we need
to double down security it's getting out
of control we can't handle it of course
so live i'm telling you live nationally
on the hook for that
what do you got jen
so this is an update to the video of the
woman attacking a man on a delta flight
people found out she used to model for
playboy and she was a former raiderette
really
so if you keep scrolling down there's a
bunch of photos she was she came out a
bunch of photos
such an
[ __ ] she kind of is that a trading
guard
limerock
she's a model in the 80s yeah i guess
back in the day she was a really hot
raider at
baywatch wow she's pretty oh yeah
i want it's real super pretty i wonder
what happens to her i should get so
busted oh she's definitely in so much
trouble
oh she's [ __ ] the outside oh wow
doing the damn thing
but yeah just okay
why do you go delta lady check this out
she's hot
um yeah she's really pretty
it's a shame she turned such an [ __ ]
yeah yeah
they call her the delta lady
she's got a ton of pictures yeah they
have a model you know
um
okay hey can you see it's so critical
right man
hey do you mind a model not like
criticizing
[Applause]
okay do you have to like comment on
everything he says and i'm just saying a
model with pages
on this website
i think the biggest thing is of course
you can talk i think you drive tesla but
i think the biggest thing
i think the biggest thing is
the surprise these barstool posts in the
picture that's what i'm saying
yeah there's a ton of pictures that she
got the guy fine
but also i read about her that she she
had like problems recently too like the
last few years getting arrested for
being drunk and oh
really bad times probably like so that
was just like the that's kind of rock
bottom yeah that has to be wrong with
anyone that's that mad yeah she's going
to punch an old man in the face over
here
is it on
something happened yeah when her mask
isn't on
she's she wasn't all there for sure
is she married her kids
pictures it's pretty crazy what happened
she's she's my type to a t i tell you
that much
type in delta 51 51. okay 51. yeah all
right see i'd assume those are 80 should
be 20 something yeah i guess 80s then
i didn't think she was going to be that
old
but what does she do
she was on baywatch too yeah she was
that one picture that we saw oh wow
so those are those pictures from 95. the
original late 80s and early 90s maybe i
don't think late 80s i think 90s the
pictures look so crazy though federal
she's 51 so
maybe uh maybe 90. some [ __ ] oh yeah
kind of a fan at this point
but she has a job they're obviously
going to fire she was a real estate
agent
i don't know what's going to happen with
that now i feel like would they increase
i think what she's going to say is i was
i was on medication and i was drunk
right that's exactly the one yeah i
thought that's what she already tried to
say yeah no a lot of people say ambiance
ambience i was and i was on and i was on
drugs and then she'll apologize but
she's still gonna pay it's going to cost
is she a real estate agent in l.a um
hold on i have some article here
if i said that that's the thing about
this i guess if she runs her own real
estate agency at that age she's probably
not working for a big corporation if she
runs her own she'll be fine she'll be
she'll be on a timeout
yeah she's lay low so that's her that's
her right now yeah okay well 51
real oh 80 year old man in california
yeah i was 80 dude a few years working a
real estate agent in california you
recognized oh she recently moved to
florida
for 13 years in los angeles
all right
just two grown children that should be
it sucks i mean and her rap sheets like
uh she went a little crazy so she has
more of this she's a little here's like
her history right here oh [ __ ] oh okay
you can start from the bottom here in
2020.
it's pretty recent though you know
uh court records show that her
sister-in-law monica
filed for domestic protection
documents say cornwall has a history of
violent outbursts and destructive
erratic behavior there you go she
allegedly threatened cummings with voice
messages saying you're you are dead okay
can't have that um cornwall in 2020
december cornwall has rested and pleaded
no costs having blood alcohol level of
0.08 uh court wrecks show she was since
36 months of probation all right keep
going
she enrolled in the alcohol program
cornwall was arrest for a dui after she
crashed her car into a tree in santa
rosa beach florida okay and then she got
aggressive with the cops who responded
she refused to give her name or get out
of the car when she did accidentally she
began going after first responders oh
wow
hey we had a while
yeah
the weirdest attractive
uh
sounds like wow wow you're a wild one
probably a crack to the jaw by some some
first responder woman yeah december 23rd
you go cornwall is seen on video
punching scratch and spend an older male
pastor over her mask she's later
arrested in atlanta yeah she's been uh
released on twenty thousand dollars and
homie was eighty years old right she has
she has i think people said that i don't
know she has an alcohol she has a major
alcohol she has a substance abuse
problem for sure and it takes her out of
herself or it brings her into her real
life
yeah they say alcohol brings out the
real self right so yeah she just might
be an [ __ ] there you go she might be
just an [ __ ] and i'm gonna go with
that usually it's like you know
people just i don't know yeah
she's a loud one she's wild again
she's a wild cat man
so this is the most recent uh
prison bay that's going viral i guess
this girl posted how does she have she
is 19. okay
uh she is currently in a juvenile
detention center for a crime that she
committed when she was 16. i said she's
22 now
is she 22 yeah i don't know 22 even
better than better out um but she was
arrested because she stabbed a girl in
the neck
i can't let joe i guess uh earlier in
this month
posted a photo of herself onto facebook
where it garnered a lot of attention and
now people are offering to pay her bond
she actually
wrote a status update saying thank you
for all of the support and she then
linked a way for people to send money so
she could buy stuff through commissary
how much longer is she in jail for uh
she's in
there for seven years from uh i don't
know but a lot of terrible health
conditions after
yeah she's very pretty
prison you're going to follow her now
the lady died
she's super pretty it doesn't know that
wouldn't be murder she was she they
would say that yeah she'd be away a lot
longer yeah then seven years well damn
that's a long time
step a girl in the net
now she's 22 so she's a different person
[Music]
[Laughter]
got ourselves a couple wild tom cat okay
yeah she's pretty man
yeah real pretty
this is for chappelle
there was an incident with an alexa
recently where this little girl asked
alexa alexa told me to do a challenge
alexa then proceeded to say well i did a
quick search on the web and this is what
i think you should do and it proceeds to
tell her to put a
plug into the outlet halfway take a
penny and touch it the remaining part of
the metal from the uh plug which would
then did someone hacking their system
television is this actual election no
this is actual alexa and i guess it
picked up searches that were popular
yeah it was one of these like online
challenges people were doing maybe like
a year or two ago alex is all i searched
the dark web you should take a knife and
stab your mom yeah that's basically what
happened yeah thankfully that little
girl was with her mom the little girl
didn't do it the mom freaked out tweeted
at amazon about this and they said they
actually went through their services
their service and
took that entire thing out because i
guess that's the thing you you could get
if people kept asking tell me do a
challenge
on amazon you just get weird [ __ ] from
yeah why the [ __ ] would they
because they went through uh the most
popular search at the time and that
happened to be the most popular search
for
tell me to do a challenge i would throw
that damn thing off a mountain i'm
telling you don't trust that [ __ ]
thing you have one i got one for
christmas
what are you going to do with it
what do you mean the uh
i don't even use siri oh i actually are
you serious i i never used to use alexa
but now you can do it for anything yeah
what's the weather in kansas city uh
what's weather today well you just you
know she says everything where can i
find uh you know a [ __ ]
i don't know offender the you know yeah
you can turn on lights turn off lights
you can
give me a recipe as you're in the
kitchen they'll give you a recipe yeah
play your favorite songs yeah the rest
but i still wouldn't give him yeah i
don't trust it either it's downloading
all the employees yeah how do you know
how you know how you all know it's
always it has to because
it's listening yeah it shows your phone
right oh because then it tells you yeah
man the things that you like and
whatever super suspect
your phone's probably doing the same
thing right yeah
the phone's probably doing the same
thing you'll see a little orange dot on
top if it's listed yeah so they said oh
really yeah
nsa isn't there you know
i don't know man but yeah i don't trust
it alex is just too much the phone i
have to have my phone regardless i just
think that we're gonna ultimately with
with robots and robotics we're gonna be
it's
you have to give in it's just inevitable
but not right now it's just gonna be too
easy your car your car's already a robot
that ferrari does have computer stuff in
it like a car like like a screen screen
no no no it's always i mean it has like
a little one where you can get like
navigation connect the apple play yeah
the carplay that's about it though
that's it it's not like a big what about
when you back up do you have a camera
yeah yeah but all that stuff like let's
say i shot someone let's say i killed
christian then went on a
speed chase in my ferrari they they get
you with the navigation the gps they
track they can log into the car and see
where your car is at not only that what
i didn't realize also i didn't know that
yeah you know if you're gonna kill
someone doing like an 80s car well
here's what's really frustrating i'm not
gonna kill anybody your car
every they have monitors in on corners
on street corners that are reading your
license plate 24 7. when your license
plate is of a stolen vehicle or your
license plate is you know the tags or
whatever it'll send a signal to a nearby
patrol car patrol car comes over and
pulls you over happened to me in arizona
they have really wait they
first of all they have cameras so
everywhere like that accident when i
saved those kiddos
they had cameras all over the highway
they had it all on camera everything
isn't that crazy everything and well and
you could see that it was you and i oh
dude to a t it's nuts it brought up on
the left
yeah and so now your license plate is
being tracked all the time so when my
car got stolen they go the cops said oh
oh we'll find it we'll probably find it
within next 12 hours i go what do you
mean because because we have
we have people running plates all day
long any time a car a cop car is behind
you that that they need to run plates
like if you have outstanding warrant
expired yeah now they have machines now
they have cameras that are doing that
automatically
but also like you're at a red light or
something yeah whatever man crazy if
you're if you're gonna commit a crime
they can they use the ping off your
phone because your phone's always
pinging to the the towers right so they
can if you're like man i wasn't there
where you were i was in manhattan at two
o'clock like weird your cell phone was
we see the ping from the tower it
reached damn being tracked at all you're
so [ __ ] these days during committee
crime you're doing a 1980 car and you
don't have a cell phone leave the cell
phone behind well in in mexico and i
don't know if they do it anymore it's
called the eye in the sky they have they
have a plane that circles the entire
city of say mexico city juarez whatever
right
and it takes pictures
of the entire city now why is that just
keeps taking pictures
well
police officers killed by the cartel she
gets in her car they shoot
you can see from the satellite from the
plane imagery the car
you can see a fire coming out of the car
you can see her car roll to a stop and
they just put it all together and then
they just follow that card but they
don't do [ __ ]
they follow that card eight out of 10
murders go unsolved correct because they
stopped using it but they follow that
car back to the safe house and crippled
took down a whole cartel was on apr
but then they were but as american
technology and mexican governments like
we're not using that [ __ ] but if they
wanted they can do all kinds of things
like that so many things yeah well to
talk about putting a tax on uh how many
miles you drive oh really issue with
that is if you think about the tax on
mileage is that means the governments
have access to your car how far you
drive so you know exactly where you're
at at all times well figure it out
people i'll tell you what they do now so
you go you know what i'm gonna buy a
house in vegas and i'm just gonna say i
live there six months a year and they go
very cool is that what you're going to
do good and but you go there like you
know one week
that's great is that what you're going
to say on your on your tax return could
um tell you what we're going to do we're
going to do a quick little thing all
we're going to do is check your cell
phone records oh yeah have you been in
and or how about your credit cards you
haven't even there's ways around this
yeah my friends yeah but with your phone
they just go but my friends do it you
were never there no all you just get
another phone put in your name and have
your parents live in that house and have
them use your cell phone credit cards
very tough to prove right
but how do they but then what about if
they you're also in la and you're there
so now it's one of your family plan it's
under the family plan how are you going
to prove who's using which cell phone
it's all under the same name you have
six different
people do it accounts
the time really all the time you'd have
to have your family living there though
yeah but you're still getting the tax
break and your family has lived
somewhere anyways you put mom and dad in
florida
and i just gave it all away
great so now i'm [ __ ]
cheating the irs yep
what did you get jen
here we go you ever put whiskey in your
coffee
never
what a shame
so this tom cruise deep fake actor has
created a whole career for himself
online doing deep fakes of
tom cruise doing random things and he
says that he thinks deep fake technology
is neutral and there's nothing bad about
it well that's not true whereas a lot of
people especially i believe it was
justin bieber who was really angry about
his account because he thought it was
actually tom cruise and he said this
could potentially trick so many other
people for sure thinking like oh this is
my friend but but this is like a drug
dealer like drugs aren't bad for you
it's like well you might throw your
money through drugs dude this guy being
like oh this it's not bad
that's how you make a living dude so of
course you're pushing that narrative
yeah he's saying that in the future
maybe
i guess somebody the use of somebody's
face could fall under
intellectual property and you would then
pay them in order to have a license i
think that's true i'm surprised
already yeah that's the surprising part
i'm so busy
social media has no clue he's like
filming impossible whatever mission
possible 19.
so he's like what i'm trying to draw
this [ __ ] plane and i did see a video
of him on a [ __ ] plane on the top of
a plane oh yeah like he's ready for
mission impossible whatever night
he's on top of a plane dude jesus like
it's like
it's tuesday no like someone else is
flying he's on top of the the wings like
he's like hanging he's actually hanging
off the wing in real life like an old
school like 1940s world war ii [ __ ] he's
unbelievable
is that real this one's real i think no
there's so much the yellow one that's
recently
look at him
jesus
and he's also 70.
yeah that scares me is he 70. he's 60
years old now
still looking for a helicopter himself
in the last mission impossible i'm sure
i mean he does all this he does all
right he's such a badass yeah
look at him it's crazy that's a tuesday
that's a tuesday
and they're not even filming it he's
just getting ready to do it
jesus christ insane dude yeah i'm not
interested dude his social media be so
lit if you decided to like do a selfie
up there
you're wearing tom cruise like what all
right [ __ ] social media i watched
will smith's new show on disney plus uh
did you like it you search them for
answers i i i have to say no i know it i
you know they're starting one is about
studying sound
so they go to a volcano and they study
the sound and then they go to does he go
to cool places then another guy like
studied that
then there's light and he goes all the
way to the bottom of the ocean and it's
yeah and it's dark but then they have
jellyfish that you see it's really dark
it's cool that's cool it's cool and he's
with like experts
yeah it's just
it's just i'm not i'm just not the
sizzle
i i would never watch it but yeah the
sizzle looks cool i i have to say i
watched it i was like boy how many have
you just won the episode i watched i
watched three and i found myself fast
forwarding you know one was like the
study of swarms and the stuff
of sound
but there's a guy who's they take along
who's blind and he just he comes along
he climb on everest and he's blind and
then he went to the edge of this volcano
and you fell it
well he he because he's watching he's
been blind since he was 13.
so he can feel so he can hear things he
can hear very differently the way we do
so he feels hears things in his body so
what he does is his his like he can hear
as well behind him as he can in front of
him sure
yeah he's like he's like a pad he's a
bad and also you know what he is he's
daredevil yep but also what's really
interesting is that
when you have been blind that long you
actually your your whole body becomes
like an ear you can feel sound waves
better
you you develop the ability to
to feel sounds let me guess you felt the
heat of the volcano yeah well he goes
can you hear that can you feel that and
that guy was like everybody can guys
like no and he said no and he said well
it's really weird you say that because
our machine is picking up on exactly
what you're talking about and he is
hearing it he was hearing it way back
there
because sound moves air yeah and you can
feel the air change now is that blind
guy in every episode
no i think he was done like
two oh wow but he's a reoccurring
character yeah too much it's too much
exhausting well you don't think they do
it every time in every every scenario
like do you feel it
yeah it's no i'm good for one episode it
might have been the first episode but
it's it's just a little yeah
that'd be cool if they like have them
jump into like uh
the ocean and there's great whites like
do you feel them
yeah now here you go
use the echo location to describe i
remember hearing about this guy no it's
a different kid but he could like walk
through here without knowing as you're
removing he's 13 months old because of
retinal cancer poor kid you know
location like sonar with the dolphins
that's what bass go through it's
daredevil
yeah and apparently sperm wells do it
too there you go that's what bats do
yeah
oh do you think yeah yeah there was a
cool thing where there was there were
these two women were swimming with sperm
whales and doing what and they they were
listening to them and they sound like a
chainsaw
like it's really loud and they were deaf
underwater i mean blind underwater no
the the but the
whales will they use echolocation
to tell what something like that
man they're like
i'm kind of into it it is it's cool
it is cool to see giant sperm whales and
you're just if the blind guy for 10
episodes that would be exhausting
everywhere we go
no i i yeah are they in a helicopter
like do you know what we're in right now
he's like you [ __ ] me it was really
it was very moving to see him actually
at the
volcano and just feeling it but he
couldn't see i don't know
you're all set
i don't know
what's another episode first what is the
feeling i have sometimes i feel like
wait time let me ask you this and be
honest do you have one those signs in
your house that say live laugh love
[Music]
no but i know i'm talking you know you
do though a little bit yeah well maybe
one of those maybe i'll wear it on the
inside and do you have a i wear one on
my heart yeah do you have a magnet on
your fish says good friends good times
do you have one of those i don't but i
i'm going to get that as a tattoo
because you're kind of going that way
right am i yeah
good friends good times though you know
what i mean when you're having but you
know what i mean when you're having like
a meal and stuff and then you're like
this like you go like this you go okay
really guys right guys guys you
acknowledge it good friends good times
am i right cheers yeah yeah yeah and
then they go come on yeah like that yeah
yeah
love laughs love live and laugh you know
yeah every girl single had that on her
wall
you got it from target i'm like all
right every single girl live laugh love
and when i was growing really sucked
yeah when i was working out literally
every girl had
the
couple kissing
do you remember that couple that were
kissing
oh it's an old school picture it's black
and white yes and they're like this yes
every single [ __ ] girl i knew had
that type of black and it was it was a
french it was it was this one old school
that that's it right there that's right
and there's a soldier coming back from
war uh no that's not the one there was
another one there was a french one the
other french or it's black and white and
they and they tried they stood for money
later on because it was such a popular
thing well there are certain things that
uh just over time when you're a single
man you go in a girl's house like i had
a thing there is that one that one right
there which one hold on that one no no
no go right there which one there bob
right there the one the far left one one
left yep right yeah right there right
there yeah
it's a good pick it's a great outfit by
the way well that's paris man paris is
incredibly in the 50s
paris is [ __ ] just awesome look at
times live laughs by the way he's got a
cigarette in his hand he's like [ __ ]
i'm kissing my girl but every girl had
that picture in their house you have you
been to paris no i think you'd love it
i think you'd love rome in paris dude
yeah i'm surprised you haven't been it's
just the whole deal i know but you have
to spend about three weeks oh no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
i've got any pics but you'd have to go
face with friends
i don't think so facetiming from there
no good eiffel tower face time you [ __ ]
no that you'd have to you'd run into no
i'm sure i would like it it's just with
my kid like my kids are there so it's
it's it's really weird
when we were younger like i missed out
on those days yeah i missed out on those
days yeah like traveling like
what are you up to i'm just getting my
backpack i'm going like i miss those
days or just having money when you're in
your when you're 30
and going for me it was a grind in my
third that's right so i couldn't take a
break and go to [ __ ]
i know
you were fighting let's get punched in
the face you can't go to paris i mean no
did have kind of fortunate yeah when i
was fighting can't afford yeah now you
can afford it it's like i'm not going
well you got your kids yeah my kids
you're not gonna be away from your kids
my kids would rather go to the holiday
inn up the street [ __ ] around on the
phones that's right instead of fly 18
hours to paris yeah because i when i
would go to paris as a young man
it was the greatest thing in the world
rome and paris were like but i get that
same feeling like i check some of those
boxes like when i go to new york and
like if i'm with you or phone with jay's
friend jason they know new york can get
like the real new york vibe
i'm good dude yeah
i don't need to go to paris or italy new
york and people know what the [ __ ]
going on it's fantastic or philly my
boy's at suplex if philly take you
around the best restaurant you're
hanging up bars
or like when when we went to uh uh
ireland gym we're in dublin we're like
at the oldest bar and there's there's uh
you did it you know what i mean bullet
holes in the in the walls from like the
old civil war yeah you know that's what
i'm talking about a little bit from that
history that fear yeah it's cool yeah
but yeah girls always had that or live
laugh love i had a theory where if a
girl had a lava lamp she was definitely
up for anal i don't know what yeah
what yeah i don't know
when i was younger i was like 20 i'm
like there's a lava lamp she's into it
right how'd you come up with it because
she's just an earth mother and
everything's like i don't know it's like
it's hot open to all possibilities yeah
it's like lava lamp oh it's we got a
freak on our hands well so that's very
interesting because my buddy and i dove
and i used to talk about how you know
when i see a girl in a fiero and she's
got lip liner and she's got dice hanging
from the i find that well back in the
day that looks like she needs some help
with some jean shorts on yeah yeah yeah
i like a little you know you drink
kool-aid for breakfast she probably left
she probably left the house to do
laundry and grab a jamba juice yeah yeah
not a ton of money yeah yeah
yeah those are cool
no it is now i feel now like instead of
fear it's like uh
i guess maybe a tesla or it's like a
civic yeah i see a hot girl in silver
i'm like yeah man now now my buddy
is uh he's in florida and he's with his
mom and dad and they're they're on this
vacation and he's well he's 30 well he
might be older he went on vacation 33.
sure and uh he's just hanging out and
he's a little bored but he's with his
parents and he's an only child
and uh mom is southern and she's a lady
she's a lady dad is a conservative man i
mean they're just you know
and uh and my buddy sees the cleaning
the cleaning gal
she cleans their parents place and then
he comes and starts cleaning his place
and he's like this lady is young and hot
and she's also
she's just working for a living yeah you
know what i mean and he just and he
starts talking to her
and he's good-looking guy and
well they start they start kissing yeah
yeah she mop that dude and then yep and
then he
he starts uh he starts to get in a
little
situation she she starts
going to town on his on his wiener you
understand oh well i understand start
something i understand
keep going and that's all good yeah and
mom well she had the door a little bit
she forgot that the door had been you
know when you keep the thing there yeah
mom came in
mama saw something mom saw her
she's a man he's sucked by the [ __ ]
cleaning gal wow that's hot and yep of
course it's hot yeah and try colombian
correct
correct sir that brown skin correct sir
that caramel skin correct positive
attitude he's a good looking guy what
else makes me
rock hard to think about this i didn't
speak a word of english so you're trying
to navigate you know what doesn't have a
language love love the language you love
[ __ ] you insane you see a rock hard dick
yeah
and he said i don't know
you don't have to say much and now he's
at lunch
at brunch or breakfast with his mom and
dad and he and his mom's just looking at
him and and he's like oh this is so bad
and she goes you don't even know her you
you had just met her and she's cleaning
the room and this is what happens i
would say you know i get out i go i love
her mom oh god
his dad goes like this his dad goes his
dad goes let's change the subject and
they never talked about it no
no yeah
he said he was he doesn't get
embarrassed he's like us oh that was i
was so embarrassed that would do it dude
so have your mom walk in on that show
so embarrassed and just getting sucked
off i mean by the maid like arnold and
it's like and then asked me and it's
like you barely know her yeah
what's the point i bet i love her
yeah my mom would love at first sight i
mean it is worth it again no things
happen
man
yeah what a great time for that day what
a great experience
you know what he was a young handsome
guy when you're young and handsome and a
big old athlete you know what there's
nothing wrong with that i'm such a
[ __ ] prude i would never oh
are you kidding me yeah i'd be like well
i mean hold on let's hold on chappelle
and i want you to open your heart and
your mind here no good friends good
times here good friends good friends
good friends good times good friends
good friends live laugh love but
we've been around chappelle a lot i've
been around way more than you i'm on the
road never seen his penis so you got to
think about that before you talk about
i'm going to say that's why i'm trying
to open them up right now that's why i'm
trying to tell him he's safe here yeah
this is safe
so so let me let me pick
so let's say oh we're heading to florida
tomorrow uh dania florida fort
lauderdale florida danny improv thursday
friday saturday bringing new year's with
your boy let's say you don't have your
girl
right and we have the airbnb we get to
early we gotta go check in you can't
check in early it's an airbnb you can't
check in early no we gotta leave our
back somewhere so like hey boys i'm
gonna get the room up top like all right
chappelle go go get your room you walk
in there and there's just she's cleaning
your life she's getting your room right
now it's a colombian giving you a turn
down yes she's eating some chocolates
chocolate she's pulling the pillows
getting the towels and she she's a tent
yeah
but she's in that maids outfit so she's
dressed down with her hair pulled back
not a lot of makeup but you can see
there's nothing against me makeup more
exciting you could just when you see a
diamond in the rough where you're like
oh you're dressed like that and i can
tell right now that you're a you're a
yeah that made outfit anyhow no curve
and by the way she could be she could be
stripping but no she's working for a
living
honest yes honest working honestly hard
working honest [ __ ] living a good
woman you are pinchios
oh excuse me she was like poppy oh boy
me she goes
like oh i'm just dropping my bag she
goes oh my god oh my bueno bueno oh
jesus and the next thing she's taken
back she's taken her back yeah and she i
i i do for you but your english is
terrible i do for you i do for you she
puts that down starts rubbing your back
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
here yeah and we'll spell come down and
you go just give it a second you you
panic are you are you kissing her not
yet bring up bring up the hot colombians
not colombian regular gals
colombia colombian maids maids
it might be but let's just see what we
get
wow 105 bucks oh [ __ ] okay okay oh [ __ ]
go to the top right go the top right
she's in a bikini she's just she's
cleaning your room dude she's cleaning
your room she's just working
so now chappelle yeah chappelle yeah and
she goes obviously she's a nympho some
there are people out there that just get
off on stranger sex and she's a nympho
now okay and that exists look that's
that's her on the right that's you on
the bottom well look at her on the left
there come on chappelle she's no she's
just she's dressed like that on the left
yes there you go okay yeah now
now
now she says something to the effect of
now this it says hot colombian made with
big tits gives up the ass for extra i
got one pesos she goes my boyfriend my
boyfriend
is a huge fan but i listen to you you
are so funny the other guy's not so much
but you are oh no no no no no
no no i don't know what i can't do no
he's too good of a guy because he finds
out your boyfriend here's my thing my my
boyfriend he no my ex boyfriend my
boyfriend he he hit me my ex my ex he
hit me i is this me as a single man yeah
you get me you get me through all my
trauma i see you answer i forget i
forget come on i forget
you're getting ready and she's on button
her shirt while she's saying this should
i forget i forget i forget no she hugs
you she hugs you and she can feel them
the knack you feel that i just want to
hug you because i'm excited she says to
you but you feel sorry for her because
she's like my boyfriend he hit he did
you know what she says she says i i
don't have too much but my gift to you
is this
and she just and she
yeah and we just see her and she just
she see that she says i i'm i've been
attracted to you for the day that's you
on the bottom there the point is
chappelle are you what are you going to
do in that situation
yeah i would i would tense the [ __ ] up
you would get awkward and run out and go
brandon
yeah the [ __ ] going on in here your
boyfriend did that this is unreal
hey boys doesn't go to lunch
i gotta help this person out
chappelle made a mess up there i'll be
down a little i am i am outraged and
furious yeah give me a six inch meatball
put it down a little bit do you have any
bruises yeah give me a secret meatball
be down a little bit
and you just kicked you should know what
you just gave me a little all right
okay no i'm kindly walking yeah i'd be
tense as [ __ ] and i'd slap you in a
situation like that i'd go
shoves in the game let's flip it on the
ass
i'm like yeah coming in you can come and
go that'd be a tough one
this is unreal he used to hit you that's
crazy
i don't get down i thought that's one
thing i will not put up with
are we we're not making light of any
kind of domestic violence no no no no no
no no i get it i get it it's a
hypothetical situation it is all
hypothetical
exists and that person and then i'd go
i'd go well this weather's muggy i'm
going to take my pants off yeah i'm too
hot she's definitely suggesting she says
no she's she's wearing all right and
then i'll not go do you can i put some
shorts on it's hot aren't you crying
she's hot are you hot
this is so hot yeah i'm
as you guys are making left she goes
i have confession to me
it's
i just i like you but
brian is my number one
and i'd say brian is my friend
and you know i'd say i'd say weird so
beautiful i'd say where
get them here
and i'd say you know one thing i like to
live by is live love laughs and good
friends good times guys good friends
good times that's it and what's mine is
his
that whole story gave me anxiety and
then we date and then we we yeah and
then she has two boyfriends yeah she has
two boyfriends yeah i'm one it's like
the movie it's like the movie savages
with those two guys that's what i was
that's literally sad
we moved to laguna beach i leave my
family do you remember what she said
about the one guy she goes he has
wargasms yeah and he felt like he felt
like warm wood and the other felt like
hard yeah and she didn't say he's [ __ ]
me like he's trying to uh get the anger
out yes yeah that was hard just christ
oh my god that movie that was taylor
kitsch or whatever he played there oh my
god that was a good movie he's in kick
ass he's the guy from kick ass the other
guy is a dime piece what's this called
lively savages with the cards blake
livestream oh [ __ ] and then and she and
she's
yeah she had two boyfriends oh dude
taylor kish and then aaron taylor and
then selma hikes the leader of the
cartel oh that's on benitez
oh he's good he's great
with their brothers and oh that's right
they're not brothers no they're not
friends yeah what happened what happened
to him he's a good looking kid this uh
they were both the one on the right's
blowing up the one the right kick ass uh
he's been a bunch of you got the long
hair yeah super badass okay yeah
he slimmed down for kick ass
hands oh that movie is hot oh savages
she has two boys you know you know my
biggest uh kidnapper my biggest issue
with with uh
all that you this whole scenario you
pointed what is it man stds or some [ __ ]
yeah i don't know that person oh my god
oh man this is why you're driving i
don't know what i can tell you then this
way drive 65 miles an hour down the
highway yeah don't don't don't change
it's less hassle i got you i don't i
don't know that person i don't know what
they're capable of who is this that's uh
aaron tyler's wife oh yeah that's the
dude she's a director right i think
somebody
she's she's a producer or she produced
kick ass or something like that right i
don't see that oh he's a milf chaser huh
she's 31 she's she's oh i appreciate
that is that right yeah yes that is so
right dude he doesn't see age he doesn't
i age i love when dude you don't see age
i'm impressed well done sir
ain't nothing wrong with that at all
[ __ ] now that's impressive there's just
some controversy behind their marriage
why
uh because she knew him when he was a
kid um because he was a child actor oh
yeah so like i guess she left her
husband to be with him when he's
broken he was only 18. uh when they got
together yeah she had some teeth and
gums on her huh
they fell in love you dude love has no
age it has no age well he's i like his
he's buff he's got it oh he's a grey
body yeah he's working holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
great body yeah he's working with
somebody you go the one where they're
both in a bathing suit she's in the one
piece oh yeah man
he's body look at that dude he's got the
beard and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah she's
looking she's got a tail piece she looks
sweet though he's got legs and a tail
piece am i wrong he's bodied up dude
think about the girls he could get and
he goes you know what i'm wrong with the
older one man he likes vintage wines
vintage cars vintage women yep she's got
she's well put together she's right
surprised she's the brian cowan of women
all right how old is she 64. 54. that's
my same age as brian and he's good and
no are you [ __ ] me papa
you know i like to [ __ ] on you not even
closed yeah are you [ __ ] me all
right he's a beautiful man look at that
oh he's that boy is fine
that body the hair you're all right
about those teeth brenda yeah she kind
of reminds me of the mom from the movie
hereditary
i don't know if i've seen that one of
course i haven't i i i like her i'm i'm
i'm a fan
she's probably i bet she probably uh
mentally challenges him that's what he
likes that's right oh yeah that's uh
nicolette who i love
oh she's great she's so good she's a
hell of a she's such a good actress oh
yeah
well you think cat
you think they look similar i see a
little bit more i see a little bit here
maybe not in here
i think one looks like the other
but uh
yeah anyway god bless good for him good
[ __ ]
well end of the day um live laugh love
but i think uh that's what this and the
theme is called live last week
and i don't like that chappelle you're
you're laughing you're loving but you're
not living dude i ca that's a tough way
to live for me i'm just too i like you
said you know what we know about you you
like what i love about you is that you
are well no chappelle's
sho pals into
things that like i think chappelle loves
stand stand-up he loves writing he loves
that sort of you're talking about chicks
ideas yeah yeah but he's
he's a conservative man you're not
tempted he's naturally conservative
naturally
conservative yeah you and i more
reckless yeah i mean girls will say
things to me after shows it's like
you're really handsome and i'm like
thank you yeah yeah i don't have much to
say to that
yeah you're a good guy
i don't i'm not being disrespectful you
know i just you're good
don't change
what would you do i feel like you're
kind of you're along lines with
chappelle not before i was more
not crazy but before i was more like
whatever but now i'm like
that's never a game your neck feels
better am i wrong it's definitely a
better mood a little bit better yeah
it's a little bit better yeah because
i've been doing that traction stuff i
think i've actually been oh you haven't
wore the brace in here though i'll do
when you guys are gone
wait wait so what would you do chen in
that situation no back then i did
persuasion
right now right now i have a girlfriend
now
if you did it hey man don't say that
dude says she got omnicron
came on the road papa here i would
definitely be hooking up a lot right now
i think i would yeah oh you would do it
because i if i tried even if that was
that random of a situation yeah really
yeah but that's not normally what i
would do but if if something happened
and i was saying i just there's just
there's just so much so many [ __ ]
questions i have in my head
yeah you could do you think too much
maybe huh
some people call it a home
right well i mean i'm sure some people
in here it'll probably happen crazy
things happen yeah sometimes sometimes
there are there are
i i've never forgot in college my i was
done with college in fact i was walking
down wisconsin avenue in washington dc
and there was a girl i'd known for four
years
she was just hot but we were always
friends because she was dating somebody
i was dating somebody and i don't know
if this ever happened to you i saw her
she saw me
i smiled i walked up and we went to hug
and kiss and we just started making the
[ __ ] out
sparks on that street emotions on that
[ __ ] street
and i dropped what i was carrying sure
and i i right we began to feel each
other up right there on the street yeah
it was like this pent up thing yeah no
laws right and i lived just down the way
you understand
i live just down the way no rules good
friends good times good friends nice
times we live once and we have left we
[ __ ] we practically started [ __ ]
like before we got to the minute
yeah and you're young and you're like i
don't give a [ __ ]
we're going here too young young yeah
yeah yeah you know you do crazy [ __ ]
right now go [ __ ] you
outside i i mean i'm i you'll find
you'll be at a party sometimes and you
hook up the girl likes you you guys you
know something happens and you're on a
fire escape in the middle of the winter
and you're getting naked and having sex
and that's happened too i'm not saying
i've done it i'm just saying that's
happened you're a wild boy you yeah you
are boy we all do things like that
christian we all christians 22 looking
for those days look at him yeah he's
[ __ ] praying for those right
yeah in a heartbeat huh you do not know
he's had that i know christian
as a woman you've done you've done
you've found yourself in in
adventurous situations yeah predicaments
yeah the cat also had a boy like a
boyfriend from like seventh grade to
like last year yeah did he let you uh
did he let you
step out dip your toe he did but i never
did it actually he did though no i felt
very obligated i think it was very
attractive that he was so secure with
himself to say like oh like we're doing
long distance do what you want there
just know like
we are still together as long as you
don't like [ __ ] that up do what you want
i thought that was very attractive of
him well i oh i feel like you and i are
two different ways yeah but you and i
are kind of they don't give a [ __ ] or
you know no but i think that you and i i
think you would agree like for me i've
never tried to control any better
here that's right i don't yeah yeah i
mean you know if you
feel like chin's coming and if you step
out i might
control do you guys imagine me you're
trying to girl you're you i would say
she she probably controls just as my
whole family my my dad they're all like
tough guys but the women control the
women right because you're dating a
vietnamese woman that that's not the
women around the world
oh yeah
vietnamese women are very attractive
yeah i mean i have to get all bossy and
[ __ ]
we don't
you know bossy comes with wild too
because sometimes i have a theory on
this sometimes when they're bossy and
controlled and they're jealous
it's because they it was your wife
i love your lava lamp theory um
and i love it and i believe it yeah
you've been actually i think years of
research and i've been so it's hard to
find it might be a truism it might be a
truism
but with with uh
with
people girls who are super bossy super
controlling of you and very jealous
i kind of like that because i think that
they are there
that would stress me they're all they're
also wild cards and they might be
[ __ ] around usually they're [ __ ]
around yeah they think you are so then
now you can get yourself into a whole
situation here negotiation is this your
way of telling chin is what girl's
[ __ ] around on him
she's vietnamese she's vietnamese that's
your kid she's not controlling but she's
definitely like
you know she don't try to look at your
phone i mean
if she's got you you're a catch so i
feel like most women would be very happy
with you i appreciate that right i mean
that you don't check your phone and [ __ ]
yeah yeah you're gonna stop we have each
other's codes but we never check our
phones yeah my girl has mine it's
usually when we take pictures when you
uh
sit down for a nice dinner does she
order for you
there's a theory that means yeah here's
the thing that's a girl
she's from that question i was about to
say that's a terrible question a very
good question
if i know where we're going like korean
bbq it's all it's me all day that's your
thing yeah whatever you're cooking she
knows so much about food she's trying
to she's learning she's yeah so i'm like
just take care of it i'll pay for it
just take it you're not picky
she picks the greatest things i love it
right right right do you sit down when
you pee or or do you sometimes okay my
neck hurts sometimes
does she order does she order your does
she order your drink too no no she tries
to have me drink the cocktails i don't
like cocktails
she'll say just try to try it yeah she
wants it to be more to my ties more
cultured not because she's trying to
control yeah i'm like nah just give me
like straight whiskey or like you know
yeah
my mom decided that my
i don't want a [ __ ] salmon and i went
to dinner with guys who had written a
book on how to be an alpha male oh my
god they tried orton for me remember
that and i was like what are you doing
how awkward is that by the way they're
just big they're both like they're tiny
they're not all they're they're good
guys but they were literally all right
five foot four five four all
yeah good guys if you wrote a book how
to be off a mail i wouldn't buy it but
the thing is they did that and they were
trying to push this book and yeah we go
to dinner and one of the things you do
in the book is you take control of the
table at dinner and you order the meal
they're with me brian who else was there
i can't remember i forget a long time
ago and he goes yeah well we'll order
the and he'll have i'm like what the
[ __ ] you literally what the [ __ ] you
doing remember that yeah it was so
awkward what are you doing don't do that
no don't do that what are you doing
let's not do an alpha thing that's not i
know i hate those stupid games now it's
so stupid so now that's why i let her
order cat do you order for uh stevie no
no but you're but you're alpha female
it's the same thing yeah but stevie it's
quick
things
i think it's very weird when someone
orders for another person
except someone tried to order for me cat
stevie got so cut conservative he is
he's very conservative now what do you
mean conservative like voting uh no no
no conservatives no just like no like
he's super conservative yeah just i
think he's much more toned down he's not
like a wild boy well he went from
shooting
porn to yeah really being domestic and
with you like
selfies with his dog which is great
he just shut it maybe he just found the
one and shut it down and i yell at him
and say it's false advertisement
yeah that's neither here nor there
[Laughter]
but but you're also but with your last
boyfriend he was kind of passive right
yeah he was very passive i don't like
doing stuff like that though ordering
for another person i want like like i
want a much more dominant man than me
because i'm already dominant as a person
yeah so i need someone more dominant
otherwise you're gonna trample yeah i
just don't feel feminine if i'm with
someone that i know you want to be
yeah people have you been in a
relationship
yeah yeah here and there i just it's
just too much work too much what he's
20. i guess you're 22 yeah nevermind
it shouldn't be that much work if you
find a good person you know what i'm
saying shouldn't be that much although
they do who are you saying you're having
a tough time with because men have so
many options with uh speed dating with
uh apps what happened
yeah but women aren't apps yeah but
apparently women a lot of women are
can't find a guy to commit to be who
will commit to them oh because there's
so many options out there for him
that's an issue shouldn't your girl pick
your outfits
hey man listen i don't like to order i
don't i don't like just all this stuff
like you know especially if it's a
restaurant you don't know that she knows
the restaurant that's fair i agree
that's fair yeah recommendations now
here's the thing yeah did she say this
flannel looked good at bass pro shops we
walked by it yeah and then you got it
and then yeah so thank you but like but
when you wake up she's like hey babe put
the hoodie in the flannel
dude with the boots she'll never lay it
out for you
if she didn't if whatever she does to
make my life easier i i'm all about it
yeah
if she laid down she does that last time
restaurants i'm like i don't want to go
through the whole menu you know what i
like just just she'll say this is this
cook a woman who can like she cooks all
the time too she's awesome
let me ask you this when you go on long
road trips does she drive
i'm asking these are good questions
first of all i do drive yeah right
but i also what i do is i open the car
door for her all the time good man oh
yeah i do that do you guys do that oh
yeah yeah okay good
yeah that's natural yeah but i drive i
try to drive unless i'm like drunk yeah
yeah yeah
so you're a good man any more questions
bro yeah i'm just trying to change
because i don't know much about how much
did you learn about a lot a lot give me
the [ __ ] for asking questions oh that's
good you got to get it out of it you got
to get it out of them
and you did get it out of them by the
way today's our the last show of 2021 oh
oh [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ]
hey come see me in oklahoma city this
weekend yeah and and you and danny of
florida fort lauderdale
we're there uh tomorrow night tomorrow
friday saturday and
oh yeah he's in oklahoma it's been an
interesting 2021. yeah he came back to
the show yep
even
with you were you on the show the entire
year
did we do it the whole year no like the
whole
yeah probably six months ish
but it feels like
back to normal i don't remember doing it
with brian
man it's good to be back home that much
hell yeah it was a dark welcome home
thank you yeah it was a dark time salt
lake city wise guys january 6 7 8
and uh i postponed spakan washington
because we're doing a fight companion
january 22nd with chris de stefano and
like we said uh this crew the thick boy
crew is in fort lauderdale florida dania
florida december 30th that's this
thursday friday saturday get your
tickets right now at fatkz.com and then
next wednesday we back shop and friends
at the hollywood improv it will be this
crew and some very [ __ ] funny we have
a very special guest that is at the
hollywood improv one show only at 8 p.m
wednesday night that [ __ ] is almost
sold out so get tickets right now if you
missed out uh two weeks ago when we did
it and then rally north carolina is
january 6 through january 8th fight
command's january 22nd and then also uh
as you guys know i left showtime so
the shob show which is formerly known as
uh below the belt formerly known as big
brown breakdown
is on thick boy youtube now if you watch
it uh audio stays the exact same you
have a new logo it stays the exact same
food truck will be on thick boy
everything's under thick boy now and
then my show
yep yeah
we're all in there um and and rockfin we
are we just added six thousand new
subscribers in the past two months so on
rockville conspiracy social club and we
just got to one a number 164 on apple
in podcast for the because we air the uh
the archived i mean sam triple is
[ __ ] hilarious is he going to be
doing shopping friends maybe i think so
yeah all right yeah i was asking be the
host yeah great i love sam he's a great
job
he's so funny anyway
conspiracy social club aka deep waters
yeah check it out
in kansas city february 25th through the
26th the comic club kc
you got your merch merch all the above
doing it doing it all man merch i love
the yellow shirt love the purple yeah
there you go all right kids love you
that's it happy new year we will see you
in 2022 fort lauderdale florida see ya
thursday friday saturday go see brian
cowan oklahoma city and that's it man
love you guys thanks for all
the downloads audio video on fire and
the kid we love you guys we have the
most loyal god damn fans god knows it
because we've been through some [ __ ] man
we've been through some [ __ ] and you
guys stuck with us and i really
appreciate it thanks for bringing me
along guys i appreciate it it's great to
have you chappelle thank you 2022 is
going to be fun
happy new year love you